shout out to jack harlow he's he's doing  arenas he's killing it killing him yeah  i'm really happy for him he's very  surprised he didn't know ray j and  brandy were brother and sister i mean i  feel like everyone knows that i mean  we feel like everyone knows that because  we know it but like i don't think it was  like  like obviously i know that right but  like maybe he didn't grow up listening  to brandy and that's i feel like the  internet tries to like  they don't they definitely make things  yeah it's not a big like it's not a  video yeah so leave him alone maybe he  didn't get around to like you know  tapping in with brandy like he said he  was like no one's ever told him that in  his life that's crazy um yeah shout out  to brandy